josé ruiz aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
balles près avec la première vraie
simulation de youtube heures c'est parti
on était dans un petit jardin à je peux
pas faire bao au rapid à cause d'un
petit jardin et qu'une petite fontaine
parce que chaque youtuber qui se doit
possède une fontaine chez lui au [ __ ]
il m'a fait peur le cours effectivement
part peut-être perd jamais eu aussi peur
d'être aussi nul
et vous avez en fait le truc c'est que
donc on a une grande ville at-on acheté
15 d'abonnés bien évidemment et en fait
les abris nous attaquent à lui sors de
chez moi donc c'est tellement scandaleux
et on les envoie vraiment malade et
finalement et le but c'est de ramasser
dans max d'abonnés partout on a trois
abonnés là par exemple
donc ça cet accroissement généralement
mère lapin aux frères à la paire voilà
lucas j'ai du mal à parler on a tous un
petit caillou tue parce qu'on a la
grosse tête
un chat ou un chien les jeunes beaux
puis c'est vrai à fond vert ça ne va pas
va pas dans le temps laisse moi te
l'expliquer bata hockey par contre que
je ramasse des arçons je vais mourir ou
des munitions et des munitions vides par
là et que de l'avis moi je vais des
balles je déballe tout août des balles
de revolver des balles de basket des
ballerines à chaque youtuber possède
aussi une magnifique salle de bains
effectivement avec un canard dedans
commun comme ici là dans la simulation
youtuber tettey ses abonnés parce qu'ils
rejettent tous un deuil ce boîtier lui
c'était un peu normal le paumé se faire
ensevelir moi j'irai dans mon bain
c'était le cas comme ça je veux mettre
en position foetale
abonnez vous tous à la chaîne bande de
bâtards allez on a gagné
ouais ok je le sais de quoi tu vas
sortir dans muscat de l'espace frères
fer bâtons mais c'est quoi cet homme mon
gars je lance la chantilly quoi l'art du
youtuber gentil héros abonnés c'est
scandaleux google france de nous exclure
de france et relance de la moutarde bon
gars de la bonne moutarde de dijon extra
relevé bien sûr chaque joueur possède un
lit deux places
bon finalement des fois invité un abonné
dormir avec lui c'est ça fait pas de
pain si on avait une maison comme ça je
pense que offrait tous un gros cache
cache nom et ma meilleure planque
ce serait ici entre ces deux vêtements
derrière pas ses vêtements former qu'un
an plus là ça ça veut dire qu'on joue un
youtube heures et pas du tout eu besoin
voilà la moitié des gens n'ont pas
compris ça de cette blague parce que les
filles elles ont beaucoup plus de
vêtements que que les dom mais compris
ou pas alors cette pièce gueule voilà ça
ça devrait être un bureau dans la
remontée bien en tirant triple bond à la
bonne excuse moi
attends attends on arrive car non pas
avant désabonner c'est plus dur d'avoir
des abonnés dans le jeu comme dans la
vraie vie c'est abusé alors chaque
youtuber possède aussi un petit potager
bio pour garder la santé la ligne on
peut le dire la fontaine le potager
c'est la vérité moi pour coup j'aimerais
fontana c'est une petite fontaine à eau
pour que des mots puissent voir sans se
mouiller tout la gorge comme il fait
quand il voit dans un bol ça n'intéresse
personne
la chaîne de l'ennui allant fait ce coup
but ça paie la note chiottes
ça n'a aucun sens moins bien quoi c'est
comme ça que squeeze défonce à 4
millions 700 mille personnes avec ses
gros biceps hors norme
tu fais quoi valentine rien dé lui la
[ __ ] mais indique hamilton
en fait ils viennent par la chapelle à
bec à l'eau mais qu'ils ont plus de
limites quoi il profite de leur corps du
foetus pour passer par la cheminée en
pleurs d'un 89 abonnés monga attend
c'est bientôt la vidéo spéciale sont
abonnés c'est bientôt l'heure attention
attention lieux de vote s'excuse
aujourd'hui ils ont surtout pour une
vidéo spéciale vous n'êtes pas dans ce
sens c'est la moitié du collège de
boules et les trous creusés dit cassama
région boulet les trous c'est vrai les
jours un acquis qui est dans un mois je
suis un boulet les trous 1 c'est pas
drôle en fait je veux abrégé rigole 118
abonnés là tu commences à être bien
parce que tu lui dis on va atteindre les
1160 of abonné je me souviens bien de ce
jour c'était un lundi après midi et en
rentrant chez moi j'avais perdu deux
abonnés afin de la blague
aujourd'hui autant de plantes blagues et
on recrute qui passe et surtout rire nos
frigos verrez qu'il n'ya rien voilà les
youtube air se nourrissent
essentiellement de pastèques et de riz
poisson pané comme tous les jeunes
d'ile-de-france avec 224 a boudé le mec
qui se fait envahir à ce point tu vas z
avec 10000 abonnés sa maison a fait les
murs ça devient des abonnés à temps et
est pas là celle-là on peut pas faire
autant de ba nul dans une même vidéo la
haye avait eu ce qui se répand en
ile-de-france bas possible qui nous
empêchent d'être drôle rendez moi mon
humour s'il vous plaît aux avoue tout en
or mon gars alors lui va nous dire
combien 100 abonnés au moi je vais
prêter les 1001 ce serait mon plus grand
rêve symptômes du virus mollahs il te
fait totalement bégayé son nez trop
aujourd'hui ça j'aurais dû prendre un
jour de congé non mais c'est vrai
j'aurais dû prendre un jour d'arrêt aux
boules dire la csbe scandaleux ce qui se
passe je vais mourir non non non non le
rêve des mille abonnés personne ne
brisera mon rêve 410 on est bientôt
abonnez-vous jorand s'il vous plaît chez
moi sur twitter je folle au bac on va
mettre des commentaires sur les vidéos
des gens connus abonnez vous svp
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire pour les
attirer je fais de la qualité ça marche
et [ __ ] on est maintenant à 86 abonnés
bon après ce totalement faux un parc one
un jour on y arrivera j'ai tenté de
chanter en rythme sur cet instru et j'ai
raté au revoir j'atteindrai mon rêve pas
seulement lors nous avons un esprit m et
moi c'est ce c'est ce quiz et un
règlement des vins dans le jeu ah oui
c'est vraiment dingue c'est faux c'est
faux totalement faux de façon à y aller
moi je mets des tchats à mes abonnés
j'ai aucun respect à aller maintenant
théodore [ __ ] j'appelle tout le monde
théodore c'est incroyable un nouveau
symptôme de la maladie qui a frappé
l'île de france récemment tout le monde
n'a pas du tout le monde théodore je
possède la chaleur non stop les noms
n'ont pas fait pas ça aux prises et
vatan [ __ ] et chevènement occupa
salon il m'a fait une culbute khan
younès et squeeze passionnant j'adore
dior
alors là on s'applaudit c'est la
première vraie blague de cette vidéo
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui je savais qu'on pouvait le
faire qu'on allait y arriver un jour
allez c'est parti maintenant on fait une
vidéo par jour
on travaille d'arrache-pied par nature
plus d'abonnés de gloire attend rundi
sont à 133 abonnés ya un problème là
dans la matrice sans déconner on fait
plus page d'accueil voilà c'est pour ça
et nos vidéos n'apparaissent plus dans
les abonnements des gens s'assoient
messager patronne youtube ça cherche pas
tu peux pas nous testent à un autre sms
du patron de google
pauvre qu'on n'aurait pas dû répondre du
coup tu es mort non jean de la google
est beaucoup trop fort pour nous en plus
la caméra elle avait arrêté deux films
et webagencies afin de cette vidéo sur
ce simulateur de youtuber j'espère que
vous a plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo que d'habitude ça me fait
penser je sais je sais pas combien
d'entre vous font des vidéos
peu importe votre âge mais en tout cas
je vous je vous soutiens dans ce que
vous faites vraiment si je fais ce que
je trouve ça bien c'est vous permet de
vous investir dans quelque chose de
créer des choses et de vous amuser tout
simplement donc je vous souhaite le
meilleur et puis j'espère que vous irez
loin que vous dépasserez ce connard de
squeeze par exemple il a comme ça devant
son ordi diouf est grande vision sur
totem attendant une prochaine vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé tuant tout le
monde portez vous bien pis